[Musique]
je m'appelle méga et j'aurai bientôt 12
ans je m'implique énormément dans deux
de mes passions que sont la danse et le
sait quand mes nombreuses pratiques ne
m'empêche pas d'être à mon enfant à
l'école
je suis une élève également très curieux
c'est pourquoi je vais vous présenter
l'application et claudia inapte à 100
que j'ai découvert grâce à une aide à sa
manière et cosy à contribuer à améliorer
notre nom bonjour je vais vous présenter
quelque chose que vous n'avez
probablement jamais entendu parler c'est
quelque chose a reçu le prix de bigorre
pour son originalité et pour sa grande
implication dans le monde et oui c'est
l'application et claudia une application
100% verte
tout a commencé avec lui que chaque rôle
le fondateur des clients il a créé
deuxième après un voyage autour du monde
car lors de ce voyage et s'est rendu
compte de la gravité du problème de la
déforestation
c'est ce qu'il a donc poussé à créer
cause hier par la suite
son siège social se trouve à huit en
berne en allemagne où travaillent une
équipe de sept à treize personnes il
travaille sur les encore publicitaires
les revenus publicitaires
les informations sur le moteur de
recherche et tout ce qui a attrait à la
plantation des arbres il traversa
partant avec b yahoo bing s'occupe des
encore publistar eyal ou des revenus
publicitaires et que dia c'est comme
safari
un moteur de recherche comme tous les
autres l'alliance si que lorsque vous
faites une recherche sur equidia vous
plantez un arbre
bref c'est un moteur de recherche car
katif qui reverse 80% de ses revenus
publicitaires à un programme de
reforestation partout dans le monde ils
plantent des arbres au burkina faso à
madagascar et au pérou il travaille
aussi en fait en partenariat avec mes
fréres et aux hedge et au burkina faso
avec guy delcourt jaxx à madagascar et
avec l'organisation pur au pérou
voici les photos d'un endroit il
pourrait planter leurs âmes évidemment
il y a peu de vivres
c'est ce qui lui pose donc à replanter
lazare dans ce genre d'endroit ici c'est
une banlieue de madea score ils ont
aussi travaillé de 2009 à 2013 avec le
fonds mondial pour la nature le wwf
programmes de reforestation pour les
forêts de djourou ena et de timmy cumac
2 fort exotique du brésil
ils ont cessé de travailler avec eux en
2013 pour des raisons d'argent et des
revenus qui causent y en avait
auparavant
leur but était et est toujours de
planter 1 million d'ha ils en sont
maintenant à 7 millions et plus mais un
lieu un nouvel objectif est arrivé cet
objectif et veulent atteindre encore
privés ce but c'est de sensibiliser les
gens encore plus à la déforestation dans
le monde car s'il n'y avait non
seulement et cozian mais la planète
entière
le monde se porterait beaucoup mieux et
surtout beaucoup plus vite
en conclusion que seule peur nous a non
seulement démontré qu'on pouvait aider à
améliorer il va évoluer le monde d'une
manière originale avec une simple
application comme ceux ci mais que nous
aussi on pouvait faire quelque chose
pour le monde et qu'il faut le faire à
l'éclosion merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]